il suffit de quelques clics pour créer
son profil sur les plateformes jobs 78
tout jobs 92 lancé fin 2010 8 elles ont
pour objectif de favoriser l'accès à un
emploi durable des personnes
bénéficiaires du rsa un service
désormais élargie aussi bien pour les
demandeurs que les recruteurs chacun
voit ce que les uns et les autres ont
publié soit en poste soit en offre est
donc peut rentrer en relation
directement on a une messagerie
sécurisée qui est intégrée dans l'outil
est donc dès que l'un ou l'autre voit
quelque chose un profil une offre qui
l'intéressent rentrer en relation
directement sans intermédiaire cette
plateforme est gratuite les demandeurs
d'emploi peuvent aujourd'hui accéder à
près de 1000 offres répartis dans les
yvelines et les hauts-de-seine deux
territoires complémentaires bassin
d'enviés bassin d'emploi du 92 et du 78
ça donne une puissance de feu
supplémentaires pour permettre le retour
à l'emploi des personnes en situation
d'insertion en matière de social en
matière d'emploi il n'y a pas de
frontières encore une fois il faut
savoir faire du partenariat en septembre
2018 les hauts-de-seine ont adhéré
activity l' agence départementale
d'insertion des yvelines
cette plate forme commune est un nouveau
symbole du rapprochement durable voulue
par les deux départements
ça avance bien j'ai bon espoir que la
fusion soit intégralement réalisée avant
la fin de l'année l ai fait la demande
et donc j'ai bon espoir d'avoir une
réponse
si aucune date n'est encore clairement
avancé pour cette fusion d'autres
mutualisation de services devrait
intervenir dans les prochains mois